so you have an amazing life I'm very
lucky wait a second seriously you were
you are you were a child actor yeah you
were well I don't know how old you were
he listen to this you were in movies
with Abbott and Costello a movie a movie
what movie was it Costello go to Mars I
mean to work with Abbott and Costa how
old were you I was seven and what did
you play I played a boy you played boy I
played boy not to be confused with boy
from Tarzan but correct Abbott and
Costello's boy uh go to Mars boy and
when you work with Adam costell did you
have a lot of face time with him I did
one scene uh Abbott was not there so I
worked with Costello right the first
scene in the movie to save everybody the
trouble yeah so you just watched that
first scene you've done the job who can
forget that first that first scene which
sets it all up you'd you'd stay what was
the setup how did Abbott and Costello
end up in a rocket ship going to Mars
and ending up in New Orleans of all
places right is that where the rocket
ship landed I think so and they thought
they were in Mars yeah good movie yeah
yeah I like it uh and and uh Costello is
like flying a plane we're talking about
rocket ships and I have one line what
makes a rocket ship go do you ever watch
that movie to see yourself as a little
boy I don't watch any of my stuff you
don't you wouldn't just be curious to
see what you were like as a little boy
no I know what I was like it's not fun
to watch yeah yeah no you know I mean
here's the thing I never really I'm I'm
one of I guess the rare grown-ups that
doesn't look back and think God my
childhood I had a fine childhood but
nobody pushed you into it no no no no no
but I I always my piano teacher became a
children's agent oh I I helped to force
her out of piano teaching the Jack Benny
Program you were on yes another genius
do you remember him oh yeah oh yeah and
you liked him eight years I worked with
him is that how you got into wanting to
be a comedian or anything just early
yeah make Jack Benny laugh and then try
to give that up and then and then um you
even hung out when you were younger with
Mel Blanc on the Jack Benny show wow he
was in the cast and don't you think Mel
Blanc Mel blank didn't live long enough
to see that you were a successful voice
guy in a cartoon but he would be so
proud of you doing The Simpsons I would
hope so yeah you would think so he was
the he was the guy who did all the
voices for the Looney Tunes so when you
were the child actor
you auditioned for and got the pilot for
Leave it to Beaver you played Eddie
Haskell yeah you were the original Eddie
Haskell which brings chills to my spine
when I say it why did you not become
Eddie Haskell in the regular TV series
um my parents they said uh you know it's
cool for you to be a working actor and
and but I was going to public school
right and they said you know if you're
going to be in a show as a part of the
cast week in and week out we're gonna
have to take it you you can't go to
public school we're gonna have to put in
one of the special Hollywood schools we
don't think that's right uh we don't
think it's right for you know 20
Teamsters are standing around going hey
the kid doesn't have it today isn't that
amazing that your parents are willing to
turn that money too I mean that said
something about it part of why he is the
way he is I imagine because even they
would not just kowtow and say we have
yeah I think that's very healthy I think
most people would be seduced and give
their child over yeah and I think that's
why someone many child actors just
up they just exactly right no my
parents were on my side wow do you ever
have regrets that I mean where is that
original pilot with you as Eddie Haskell
it's on the DVD of the the collected
Leave it to Beaver episode I'm getting
that tomorrow I gotta see it were you a
good Eddie Haskell
uh they offered you the part they
offered me the part the only time I've
ever seen it I was on with Dave one time
and he showed like a little clip of that
and I saw it out of the corner of my eye
did it flip you out it did it did I mean
you had a whole take on anything how old
were you at that time that must have
been about 10. the only thing I could
think of was that that was
pre-orthodontia me wow my teeth were out
to here a funny looking at a house yeah
it's a test
foreign